but nonetheless Donald Trump is still
freaking out right now on Twitter he's
angry he's lashing out at the
investigations he's lashing out at
everyone really and part of the reason
is because of the manna fort sentencing
but the other part of it is because of
the news that just recently broke about
his good buddy former buddy I guess
Michael Cohen because according to
emails that have now been uncovered
Michael Cohen's attorney had been
talking with Rudy Giuliani Donald
Trump's attorney and it seems likely
based on the emails that they were
dangling a pardon in front of Michael
Cohen the emails suggest that Cohen's
attorney said you can sleep well tonight
this was following the FBI raid on
Michael Cohen's office you can sleep
well tonight because you've got friends
in high places Cohen's attorney later
clarified that uh does this mean a
pardon was dangled does it mean we
talked about it maybe for about 15
seconds that's about the length of time
he says a pardon may have been dangled
in front of Cohen but that 15 seconds is
significant because that 15 seconds if a
pardon was ever dangled and ever pitched
to Michael Cohen as hey play nice you
got friends in high places there could
be a pardon waiting for you on the table
so don't screw this up that's
obstruction of justice on behalf of the
Trump team that could be obstruction of
justice on behalf of Donald Trump
himself now these reports also indicate
that the Trump administration was
worried about Michael Cohen flipping on
Donald Trump they wanted him to stay in
line they wanted him to do nothing bad
or say nothing bad that might end up
getting Donald Trump in a little bit
more trouble now of course all of this
happened prior to Michael Cohen's recent
testimony in front of Congress and that
also ties into this story because
according to Cohen's lawyer he did talk
to the lawyer who then talked to
Giuliani
a potential pardon yet just a couple
weeks ago Michael Cohen told us that he
never talked to anyone about a potential
pardon if we're to believe his lawyer
which we probably should then that would
mean that Michael Cohen did once again
lie in front of Congress a couple weeks
ago that is significant because if he
lied about this what else did he lie
about kind of throws a big monkey wrench
into the gears of everything that was
revealed during Michael Cohen's
testimony do we take it at face value
now do we assume he was telling the
truth we know he lied about this now
were there other lies there that's a big
question not so good for the information
he revealed but silver lining I guess on
this is that he did provide us with the
receipts quite literally backing up most
of what he said but these other receipts
these emails that have come out show
that he did lie at least it appears he
lied about the pardon issue not good for
Cohen but certainly not good for Trump
because again if they were dangling a
pardon in front of him if they were
trying to get him to play ball play nice
with the team not do anything that's
going to get Trump in trouble that's
obstruction of justice
that's witness tampering that's trying
to alter the potential testimony of a
witness yes that is bad yes that could
be considered an impeachable offense and
yes this could land Donald Trump in a
hell of a lot of hot water